il a choisi le club aux 14 bouclier de
brennus le versaillais léobard et a
signé un contrat de deux ans avec le
stade français paris à 18 ans elle
rejoint les espoirs du club parisien en
provenance de massy
c'est quand même le club de la capitale
j'ai grandi en région parisienne j'ai
commencé à versailles on parlait du
stade français comme comme l'un des plus
gros clubs de top 14
donc j'avais comment parler de cette
français quand j'étais petit j'avais des
étoiles dans les yeux
donc voilà ça représente ça représente
beaucoup pour moi ce jour-là léobard et
s'entraîne avec l'équipe professionnelle
sous les ordres du tacticien argentin
gonzalo quesada un moyen d'accélérer sa
progression
c'est un joueur intelligent et il est
très intelligent il
il a un gros coup de pied je pense qu'il
a une bonne une bonne organisation
s'il faut qu'ils continuent comme ça
s'est su très bien on a évidemment
identifié un potentiel intéressant chez
lui et puis il a la capacité de remplir
les plusieurs cases évidemment celle du
joueur de rugby mais aussi celle du
joueur capable de mener à la fois un
projet sportif et un projet
universitaire l'idée c'est plutôt de le
faire mature et de lui donner les moyens
de s'inscrire dans la durée dans cette
équipe et d'en faire dans les deux à
trois prochaines années le demi
d'ouverture du stade français depuis
plusieurs années les au bar et participe
aussi à des stages en équipe de france
jeunes à marcoussis avec les meilleurs
joueurs français de sa génération
pendant une semaine en octobre 47
joueurs se sont retrouvés après
plusieurs mois suite à la crise
sanitaire
elles sont plutôt bonnes pour l'instant
j'arrive à retrouver un peu mes repères
que j'avais les dernières
après j'arrive pas non plus à un terrain
où je connais personne enfin là je
connais quand même tous les joueurs on
est vraiment un groupe
donc on l'a vite des rebonds retrouve
vite les repères pour le rugbyman
yvelinois issus de la formation
versailles et sa carrière se poursuit en
équipe de france moins de 20 ans jeu de
mouvement vitesse de circulation du
ballon prise d'initiative des qualités
que les au bar et possède et doit
développer les eaux a des qualités qui
lui permet d'être performant sur
plusieurs postes
il a des qualités de franchisseur et les
qualités de passeur donc donc forcément
ce qui peut ce que l'on recherche et ce
qui peut amener l'équipe de france
mauvais à performer léobard et postule
pour une prochaine rencontre si la
situation sanitaire le permet début
janvier l'équipe de france moins de 20
ans développement doit jouer un match
contre l'italie